Magnus seemed like a normal enough kid
growing up outside Oslo but wait a
minute when he was five he could name
almost all the countries in the world
and their capitals and their populations
magnus's father Henrik didn't think that
was terribly unusual but I thought that
was normal
what got him into chess sibling rivalry
his older sister started to play so he
wanted to beat her which he did quickly
then he started winning tournaments
before long he became a celebrity one of
the first Norwegians to excel in a sport
that did not involve snow
people lined up in shopping malls to
play him when he won Magna said it was
just a game no big deal he couldn't
understand why people were making such a
fuss
oh why this
all people want to talk with me you know